[Musique]
iriez-vous très vite c'est un canular
c'est un canular tout le monde sait que c'est un
c'est un
canular complet le tout avec l'Ukraine donc vous avez
un appel téléphonique parfait quand sabbatino pour
organiser un séminaire particulier excuse américaine
courbe amazi à propos de Yura de CL mère
Lucas a pris le processus ou ce sous
Donald Trump
Rebecca voit que Milan était infesté
pour un coût américain cent Scalia
Dali a précédé cela à l'éternel s'il vous plaît
fait ne recevez pas de cadeaux ce panneau est un
engagement que nous avons pour cela définit un homme
nommé George  Yeo Texans Julianne
dokie Shahar sa danse j'observerai une
sollicitation dans - AHA - aha Bonjour
Pauline ordonnez le saut à la scène whoa don't
do est un vaca Donald Trump vous êtes
actuellement ouais lien qu'ils ont trouvé du saké
même pourquoi la prison jusqu'à  enfin les Bhakra
disent que nous ne nous soucions plus de moi Katie comment
vas-tu Dudley monsieur d'accord papa père Donald
Trump vendant messieurs les ders abandonnent une
bobine de chemita le programme Kekeya
des dollars Kim sont sécurisés la mademoiselle
Alexi  s oh non gamin l'appel honker Hamas
est divisé Irak Estonie mais le crémeux
a un dotty Texas Donald Trump II ne
tue pas une procédure un cas d'élitisme
une fille / de vous la voyez manquer à un
marché aux puces ils me disent le vaisseau
répétitif  la parité est devenue la difficulté
du processus sociétal échapper à un
processus catastrophique pour ignorer la reprise politique une clé est de
mettre en œuvre un seul démocrate accepter des
excuses renvoyer Eric sur la démence s'ils
se déchirent voila schwa le nouveau
Vols Ibaka le Donald Trump un
Rosati chaotique attribué à un homme sans amis Je mérite
un  voiture pour reconnaître oh non citoyen cette
Erica Cohen est un savon [ __ ] une
controverse s'ouvre pas un momager
- un jet ski canoë eau pure par défaut DJ
Christine sur la victime masculine traite
Chiara basi à l'onglet du concours Moya, vous pouvez
ajouter le règlement du traité de sécurité affamé
allouer mr.  Starkel a séparé la
spéciale spéciale de
la mise en accusation des Clinton ne le coupant pas du
bassin ou d'un plan stratégique américain
n'a pas demandé à Trump Mme Eden Park.
Emmerson
ib3 à la dépression d'une feuille de route, la police est un
âne, alors réservez à la maison l'animal le plus gros,
transmettez cette comparaison
Scottie le Donald Trump, ils sont des
consommateurs sont des dindes à Fox News,
ils font exprès de faire de la pizza un monsieur  Levine
oxydant chiisana garder mon âme est sur le
monopole efficace de Fox News étant votre
toxicomane d'initiative parallèle Bill Clinton
sur un yacht peut-il le démarrer il scooty le
mr.  Trump off aider un suçon danke elle
peut je commence cela via les Himalayens
ont indirectement pour moi
aimer la démocratie Sioux City panier légitime
ou ne jamais craquer ouais ils étaient pour la plupart
Lucy complètement tourné oui c'était le
fondateur s'il vous plaît ne pas ouvrir la fidélité à l'échelle
le garder ouais  Je vais prendre une subtilité pendant que vous
dites que notre démocratie ne se soucie pas des
processus Otmar pour la deuxième saveur que
Monsieur Nigel EPA a fait ne voit pas
couramment plus une tête en plastique Danielle j'ai dit que
je suis chez Ashley Hitomi
capsule de dimension politique EW Dieu EW
venez spécialement soutenir un chimérique un
olympien pour nous voir tous d'avis un
look populaire tellement américain connaître les gens chaque semaine
pour raconter ce que le tilde butte co drame
pathétiquement démocrate surtout pas de
public à Bush pour vrai maître je l'ai
demandé donc c'est des processus d'appel
pour noter tous  les carottes sur la boîte de Terrance
j'ai dit un pur être non plus un hôtel
à ce cabesnoz s'il vous plaît Donald pas de
clé d'alimentation Bush elle répond oshina Hal alerte
à ce professeur co2 qu'ils ne peuvent pas faire
Proxima Shalini est devenue s  o à ce
professeur pour montrer à l'hôte de calculer ces
livres sur les overclockeurs de chiens aucun processus
le déshonneur bikini marron scapulaire
alors faites-moi savoir publiquement ne pas
parler de certains de la politique de stratégie dont ils ont besoin
mo siestes de chat et pathétique désert polaire
escortant où est un facteur important
ouais  gâteau européen
ouais visa si heureusement conclu
ma cavité légale félon acceptable sur son
Lulu a plu à l'Amérique sa doctrine
exposer beaucoup Lotta dire statue pour servir une
action laïque ou Trump Ashley
homme efficace comme m.  Holohan de retour sur Samia a mis un
accord perspicace la défense des animaux pour Donald
Trump est un problème un passage qui
massacre à Boonville me lèche la
propre arrogance de Chris faite sur omean alors à Dale
Kayla s'il vous plaît faites un pop up ici est une
superbe qualité par rapport à ce qui est
généralement lu  sur le papier à près de
neuf détective un pourboire notre pays principalement
spa aucun endroit n'aura de porc assez stupide
Iquitos et il y a donc ne
laissez pas mes coupeurs hôpital monsieur pourquoi
CET j'allumerais juste après Casey
Pascal mr.  Trump éclatera tout ce qui
est attaché à la politique poste un
personnel propagé un discret M. Trumper Twitty
seul papier tabloïd évalué sur le
trottoir vous ne pouvez pas ok oui certainement
conclusion pub draconien remarquablement
stable Bella Quito carrousel manière polie un
récepteur comique pastel de marzi  Juliana est-
ce que je ne me dis pas avec le présent maintenant
Texas la nécessité de poursuite commerciale
qui est présente en Amérique s'assoit sur une pointe, il
a des publications de cérémonie Markham a envoyé un
paquet de travail à cette capacité sur le zoo
s'il vous plaît ne sautez pas pour l'épuiser sur le
débit Opilio refusé  fournit une chanson
la pyramide se prépare à leur déclin sur
votre maison une vérole également au Palacio
soutient la belle Nyssa somali beaucoup ce
Joseph 2,00 $ par seconde atomique a le
rend meilleur
Chris Paul Tanaka moi-même un sort juste
exhaustif Silvio palcic Jim Garrison
soul Patel's  nous ne comprenons pas que vous voyez
ne mr.  Trump a dit que si vous l'
accordez, cela dit comment laissez-moi prouver que les
paniers électoraux à Latakia réduisent
Emmett réduit réellement la verticale
électorale Anita important Polly le
répétant sur mr.  Marcus est une
attaque personnelle sur la diminution du poids pas de
dix-huit cursifs Anitra sexy polyvalent
est la
riche Piana portes jusqu'au Texas merci
beaucoup
la pré-vente oh wow